[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 à l'occasion des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques 2024
les habitants de la Communauté
d'Agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines et
les visiteurs lors de l'événement des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
pourront expérimenter les capsules
électriques et des capsules urban loop
et pour en parler avec nous je reçois
aujourd'hui Jean-Baptiste amony qui
vice-président de 50 ans en Yvelines
délégué au transport et à la mobilité
durable et maire de Villepreux bonjour
bonjour alors vous êtes en plein projet
d'aménagement des capsules électriques à
l'île de loisirs de 50 ans en Yvelines
des capsules qui seront mises à
disposition des visiteurs avant le début
des JO p2024 alors Jean-Baptiste
amélique quels sont les particularités
justement de ces capsules électriques
vous savez à l'heure où on parle de la
transition écologique et de la
transition énergétique force est de
constater qu'aujourd'hui le premier
secteur émetteur de particules fines de
CO2 donc de pollution finalement c'est
le secteur des transports et donc dans
l'objectif qui est le nôtre celui de
l'ensemble des pouvoirs publics mais
aussi de 50 ans en Yvelines de pouvoir
décarboner nos transports on avait cette
volonté d'inventer d'avancer sur la
mobilité durable et c'est le cas avec ce
cette nouvelle technologie qui se
présente à nous qui est une technologie
nancéenne française
urban loop avec donc un transport de
capsules électriques sur rail sans
batterie faut le préciser qui donc verra
le jour sous forme d'une expérimentation
à l'occasion des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques et bien de 2024 donc ça
fait un petit moment qu'on travaille
avec ce partenaire plusieurs étapes ont
été franchies on y reviendra et donc
dans un consortium qui va regrouper
urban loop l'agglomération de 50 ans en
Yvelines et qui sera l'opérateur on aura
pour cette séquence des Jeux Olympiques
ce nouveau transport innovant et durable
qui sera situé sur l'île de loisirs la
raison développée vous l'avez dit par la
société
urban loop elles vont à 50 km/h sur un
parcours de 1 km alors c'est 1 km en une
minute pourquoi vouloir expérimenter ces
capsules électriques à l'île de loisirs
alors l'île de loisir parce que ce sera
vraisemblablement
le territoire sur lequel nous aurons une
fan zone au moment des Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques nous il nous fallait un
petit tronçon un trajet pas très long
pour pouvoir expérimenter justement
cette cette nouvelle technologie on est
sur un peu plus d'un kilomètre entre
justement le l'entrée de l'île de
loisirs et ce qui est les canards là où
sera situé la la Fan Zone donc c'est
assez intéressant parce que c'est un
site évidemment qui est un des poumons
verts de l'agglomération et on va
pouvoir démontrer qu'avec cette
technologie on arrive à porter des
projets et bien de transport qui ne sont
pas lourds qui ont vocation j'aime bien
à transporter quand même un grand nombre
de personnes puisque faut rappeler que
ce sont des cabines presque
individuelles il y a une ou deux places
on peut amener son vélo ça sont
accessibles aux personnes à mobilité
réduite aussi et donc ces cabines là qui
seront sur rails sur des infrastructures
réversibles ça veut dire que si
l'expérimentation n'est pas concluante
ou si on décide que le tracé n'a pas
vocation à être pérennisé après les Jeux
Olympiques on pourra enlever ses rails
c'est finalement l'emprise foncière et
réduite très très réduite et ça rend
aussi doublement ce transport
intéressant sur le plan écologique et
environnemental puisque il est très peu
consommateur il est très rapide il a
d'ailleurs enregistré des records de
vitesse et il consomme très peu de
surface au sol cette expérimentation là
avec les jop 2024 c'est aussi pour les
tester dans des conditions de population
danse finalement oui il faut les tester
en conditions réelles moi j'ai eu
l'occasion de voir à Nancy le
démonstrateur effectivement la société
l'entreprise a fait d'énormes progrès
depuis les capsules on peut on peut les
voir aujourd'hui elles ont été exposées
notamment au salon de l'innovation le
ministre est venu les voir avec avec
Madame Idrac et on sent qu'il y a un
vrai soutien et un vrai accompagnement
aujourd'hui de l'État aussi sur ce
projet là l'Urban loop a été l'oréade du
plan d'investissement 4 du gouvernement
ce qui veut dire que l'ADEME aujourd'hui
finance en grande partie et bien ce
projet finalement le reste à charge pour
l'agglomération il est à peu près 700000
euros c'est pas énorme sur un projet de
cette ampleur et je crois que nous en
tout cas en tant que territoire
d'innovation quand on a la chance
d'avoir au moment où tous les
projecteurs seront braqués sur
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines avec les Jeux
Olympiques quand on a la chance d'avoir
une mobilité aussi innovante il faut la
tester on peut pas se permettre de
passer à côté donc je pense que ça sera
un vrai un vrai atout évidemment faut
bien que les 56 mois comprennent
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas un mode de
transport qui a vocation à irriguer le
territoire que c'est pas une alternative
au mode de transport qu'on a aujourd'hui
dans notre Plan de Déplacement c'est pas
du tout le sujet là le sujet c'est de
dire pendant 17 mois parce que l'idée
c'est ça c'est de juin 2024 à novembre
2025 on a cette plage de 17 mois pour
expérimenter ce transport normalement
tout est raccord donc on devrait être
débuté nous les travaux à l'été 2023
alors les capsules n'émettent pas de CO2
lors des essais devant le l'ancien
ministre des Transports la capsule donc
à parcouru un kilomètre en une minute
pour un coup de 47 centimes est-ce que
c'est donc un moyen de transport voué à
être moins cher et plus respectueux de
l'environnement plus respectueux de
l'environnement oui je le rappelle donc
très peu d'emprise au sol finalement on
est sur un transport sur rail mais c'est
rails l'alimentation électrique du de
des capsules se fait directement par les
rails donc en plus vous économisez le
fait d'avoir une batterie il y a pas de
batterie ça enlève un peu tous les
débats qu'on peut avoir aujourd'hui sur
l'électrique notamment sur l'automobile
quand on dit c'est très bien de dire
qu'il faut basculer sur l'électrique
mais quid après du recyclage notamment
des batteries cette fois-ci il y a pas
de batterie bon donc c'est plutôt c'est
plutôt une bonne chose la vitesse est
tout à fait intéressante nous on devrait
être aux alentours de 40 à 50 km de
mettre heure sur la portion 50 chinoise
justement sur ce sur le tracé qu'on
évoquait à l'instant donc ça rend ce
modèle très compétitif c'est sûr que
maintenant si on passe pas par la phase
d'expérimentation on ne pourra jamais
savoir si cette technologie d'Urban loop
et viable et durable sur un site urbain
et notamment en ville donc il faudra
voir comment comment l'expérimentation
se déroule en tout cas on est très
confiant et on est vraiment heureux de
pouvoir l'accueillir sur le territoire
au moment de cette belle séquence que
seront les JO 700 000 euros dans le
projet que vous avez investi parmi vos
collègues du Conseil de la Communauté
d'Agglomération certains émettent
quelques réserves Didier Fisher et lui à
50 ans en Yvelines et maire de
Coignières a estimé que c'était un
budget la question se pose en effet vous
développez les pistes cyclables les
mobilités douces et les trottinettes
électriques par exemple est-ce que les
capsules électriques ont un intérêt à
l'île de loisirs est-ce qu'il y aura là
vous avez parlé justement jusqu'en 2025
est-ce qu'il y aura un après jop 2024 et
ce qui pourront finalement développer
dans 50 ans en Yvelines de sujet sur les
interrogations qu'on peut avoir certains
de mes collègues il y avait une non pas
une volonté mais en tout cas il y avait
une confusion je crois dans leur esprit
puisque il parlait des 700000 euros
qu'on consacré à ce projet en disant
qu'on pourrait les consacrer justement à
l'aménagement de pistes cyclables mais
finalement c'est ce qu'on fait puisque
on a voté il y a plus d'un an maintenant
un schéma directeur cyclable il faut
rappeler que c'est 38 millions d'euros
d'investissement qui nous permettront
d'ici 2030 d'avoir près de 600 km
d'itinéraires cyclable sur l'ensemble du
territoire de l'agglomération et donc
des douze communes 38 millions d'euros
d'un côté d'investissement 700 000 euros
pour un projet d'expérimentation donc
évidemment on voit bien que les rapports
sont pas du tout les mêmes donc nous
notre volonté d'avancer sur
l'immobilités douces évidemment que elle
est elle est pleine elle est entière on
le voit sur le vélo avec le schéma
directeur cyclable on le voit avec les
trottinettes électriques puisque on est
passé là aussi par une expérimentation
qui a été concluante on pérenniser
aujourd'hui le dispositif et je pense
que tout le monde l'a vu ça a fait des
petits dans le département et au-delà
des frontières des Yvelines puisque un
grand nombre de collectivités et bien
ont décidé de d'avoir recours à ce type
de service de trottinette électrique en
libre-service souvent d'ailleurs avec
l'opérateur tir qui a démontré en tout
cas tout son sérieux notamment sur les
aspects de sécurité sur le territoire il
y a qu'à Paris que ça pose quelques
questions mais je m'attarderai pas sur
ce sujet là donc on continue évidemment
à avancer sur la mobilité douce pour
répondre à votre question les capsules
et ce qu'elles vont est-ce qu'on va
aller voir fleurir après un peu partout
sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines il faut
prendre des choses dans l'ordre si on
m'avait demandé est-ce que on va
généraliser le dispositif de trottinette
électrique je il y a un an je voudrais
répondu attendons de voir les
conclusions de l'expérimentation
l'expérimentation a été extrêmement
positive on pérennise le système le
service de trottinette on va bien
au-delà si demain les capsules portent
leurs fruits sur le tronçon qu'on aura
en expérimentation pendant les Jeux
Olympiques sur l'île de loisirs et bah
pourquoi pas après réfléchir sur des
opportunités ailleurs sur le territoire
faudra aussi regarder l'impact
budgétaire que ça peut avoir pour
l'intercommunalité et donc aussi pour
les communes puisqu'on sait qu'on est
dans un contexte immédiatement compliqué
en ce moment voilà et dans le cas où ça
serait développé ça serait en plus ça
serait un mode de transport en plus
c'est pas en remplacement d'un autre
mode de trans tout à fait nous on est
dans une logique d'intermodalité dans
une logique de bouquet de service on ne
pose pas les modes de transport entre
eux on est dans un département qui reste
très routier donc il y aura toujours la
place pour la voiture il faut maintenant
qu'on arrive à obtenir un report modal
de cette part automobile vers les autres
modes de transport que ce soit les
mobilités de ce qu'on a évoqué le but on
a aussi un très bon réseau de bus avec
notre nouvelle dégréation de service
public aussi qui est rentré en œuvre au
1er janvier dernier
90 lignes de bus faut pas oublier qu'on
a cette gare aussi sur le territoire il
y a la marche piétonne aussi qui fait
aussi figure de mode de déplacement à
part entière du quotidien le vélo je
l'ai dit on essaye de mettre un coup
d'accélérateur sur sur la avec le
schéma directeur donc faut pas les
opposer ils sont tous complémentaires
aujourd'hui moi je situe pas du tout
urban loop dans les modes de transport
du quotidien on l'a pas intégré dans nos
plans de déplacement au niveau de
l'interconnalité c'est vraiment une
expérimentation qu'on va mener à un
instant T pendant 17 mois si
l'expérimentation est concluante s'il y
a un intérêt pour le territoire de
Saint-Quentin d'aller plus loin on
discutera avec l'opérateur on discutera
avec l'île de France mobilité parce que
faut quand même dire qu'ils le France
mobilité nous a accordé le droit
c'est-à-dire une délégation de
compétences pour tester cette
technologie sur un territoire
d'innovation encore une fois justement
le test se fera donc en mai et les les
50 chinois pourront venir justement
l'attester tester ces capsules urban
loop merci beaucoup Jean-Baptiste
d'avoir été avec nous sur sensation et
pour revoir ou réécouter cette émission
rendez-vous sur notre site et notre
application radio sensation
[Musique]